Leon Panetta held a series of top jobs
in Washington during a widely respected
career in public service he served as
White House chief of staff under
President Clinton director of the CIA
when Osama bin Laden was killed and
Secretary of Defense under President
Obama now he is chairman and co-founder
of the Panetta Institute for Public
Policy Secretary Panetta joins us from
Nashville Tennessee secretary always
good to see you thank you so much for
joining us nice to be with you what do
you think the Secretary of State needs
to achieve in his visit to Moscow today
well I think it's very important for him
to send the kind of message that he
spoke about in Italy which is that the
Russians have a fundamental choice here
to accept some responsibility here for
what happened in Syria to try to
influence Assad never to do it again
- basically join the nations of the
world in making sure that we don't
experience another chemical attack in
Syria and for that to happen Russia has
to really make a choice whether it's
going to stick with Assad and Iran and
Hezbollah or whether it's going to join
with the United States in trying to
promote a more peaceful world but mr.
secretary the Russians have already said
that if forces used again they will meet
force with force and so have the
Iranians have they already made that
choice charlie in the world of foreign
policy the name of the game is to
obviously send all kinds of messages to
each other recognizing that we're still
a long way from any kind of direct
confrontation I don't think the Russians
want confrontation with the United
States and I don't think the United
States wants direct confrontation with
the Russians but we're in for some tough
negotiating right now in terms of really
trying to get the Russians to exert some
influence here so that Assad does not
conduct additional chemical attacks
after all Russia does bear
responsibility here they're the ones
that negotiated the agreement
they're the ones who failed to enforce
the
agreement and so they have a great deal
of responsibility to do what's right
Robert Ford the ambassador former
ambassador to Syria told me last night
that Assad has won the civil war is over
you share that judgment no I really
don't you know I think that there's no
question that Assad has been reinforced
by the Russians by Iran by Hezbollah by
the fact that no one was willing to take
him on directly and so there's no
question he has he's exerted some
strength here in terms of trying to
retain control of Syria but the fact is
that there is no future in Syria with
Assad he has killed his own people he's
committed atrocities there is no way
that a future Syria is going to continue
under an Assad regime that's a reality
and I think the Russians need to
understand that and work with us to
ultimately remove Assad from power I
don't think we ought to give up on that
what indications do you have that the
Russians might cooperate I mean there's
an AP report that says Russia had
advance knowledge of Syria's chemical
attack and it was a russian-made fighter
jet that bombed a hospital treating
victims in Syria what did you make of
that report well yeah okay it doesn't
really surprise me that the Russians
would have some sense of of what the
Syrians were up to but at the same time
I think the Russians have to decide what
is in their fundamental interest here is
it to take on the United States is it to
take on other Arab nations in the Middle
East take on the world community that
has made clear we're not going to
tolerate additional chemical attacks is
that what they want to do or do they
want to try to to work with the United
States and others to make sure that this
never happens again I think the Russians
in my experience I know when they have
an opportunity to try to move
in the right direction and this is an
opportunity for them to try to do what's
right so I don't I don't automatically
assume that Russia is going to go in the
other direction we've got it we've got
to deal with them in tough ways we've
got to make clear that we're going to
use military force again if we have to
but in the end we've got to convince
them that they've got to work with us
mr. secretary let's talk about the issue
of North Korea President Trump has just
tweeted this North Korea is looking for
trouble as you know the Pentagon has
moved an aircraft carrier off the Korean
Peninsula
tensions are quite high as of course
other military exercises going on in
South Korea do you think something may
happen this week well I worry about the
fact that April 15th is the birthday
celebration of their founder in North
Korea and every time they have a
celebration like that they tend to do
something provocative and I suspect that
they're working on either a an
additional missile shot or a nuclear
test or something to show the rest of
the world that they're you know that
that they can influence what happens in
that region so for that reason I think
it's important for us to have our force
present in the region we need to show
that we're prepared to take whatever
action is necessary to ensure that North
Korea does not engage in any deliberate
attack in that region so we've got to be
tough with them we've got to make clear
that we're not going to tolerate this
kind of provocation but at the same time
we've got to continue to try to see if
China can pursue the kind of pressure
that will bring us back to the
negotiating table
what is our redline inside of a North
Korean attack what is it that which
should cause us to take severe action I
think Charlie that the real concern here
would be that as they continue to
develop their ICBM capacity that they
try to test an ICBM
and that they're crazy enough to put a
miniaturized nuclear weapon at the top
of that ICBM in order to test it
not necessarily to attack but to test it
I think if we see that if intelligence
presents that kind of scenario that
would be very dangerous in terms of the
United States in that region and I think
would indeed cross the line in dealing
with North Korea Leon Panetta thank you
so much